(people applauding)
- Welcome to The Kelly Clarkson Show,
give it up for my band playing
Bad Habits by Ed Sheeran,
Yeah.
So we have someone on the line
who is very familiar with that song.
Can we say hi to him, everybody?
(band music)
What's up Ed Sheeran!
(audience cheering)
Get it out, get it out people.
They love you.
It is great to see you again.
I will, I'm gonna lead with this.
It is absolutely terrifying
to be singing someone's song
and then listening.
(Kelly laughs)
I was like, oh my God.
I was like, it's terrible.
I love that song though.
Bad habits is such a jam.
I love it. Why did you write that?
- Ah, thank you.
I loved your version by the way.
I was listening to your version,
wondering whether I
should have actually used
more electric guitar in it,
'cause it sounded pretty great.
(people laughing)
I wrote it,
by accident.
I was working with,
the two people that I've
made the album with Johnny,
Johnny and Fred and Fred is
primarily like a dance producer.
And he played me a tune that
he was just about to release.
It was a really, really heavy dance tune.
And I just said, you know what?
Let's just try and make something upbeat
that could also be played on
acoustic guitar life basically.
And yeah, it just kind
of happened by accident.
I wasn't expecting it to be first single
and yeah it's one of these
songs that sort of came out
and it's just kind of stuck
and it's not like it's,
it hasn't been like my
biggest charting single,
but I think it'll end up being,
- Longevity
- one of my biggest songs just over time,
- Yeah that's longevity.
- very very gradually.
- And that's the best kind of song though.
And also, I didn't want to freak you out,
but my idea was actually
to completely do it
with just a piano,
and I wanted to make
it really dark and sad
and then I didn't want to freak you out.
So I kept it like this,
(Kelly laughs)
but I love a song like that.
I feel like you write songs like that,
that you can literally
do with a huge band,
electric guitars, do it big.
You could do dance, you
can do singer songwriter.
I think it's an amazing
gift you have, songwriting.
Everybody knows that but,
so you were a mega mentor
on The Voice this season.
Super stoked about that.
But I have to ask who was
your favorite coach Ed?
(audience laughs)
I mean, who was it, just shout it out.
Just don't feel shy.
- Well Kelly, only one person,
only one person debut there.
(Kelly laughs)
- No like, I can't say.
- [Ed] It must've been
you because I still,
actually, I still have the jacket.
- You still, see, I gave you presents.
- I still have the jacket in this house.
- I will buy your love
Ed Sheeran. I will do it.
Well, no, your daughter Lyra,
which is the most beautiful name ever.
She just turned one.
So how do you think we
were talking about her
whenever you were visiting?
'Cause it was your
first time away from her
for that amount of time.
So how do you think she's changed you?
- Well, I mean, my
bedtime has shifted from,
I'm no longer going to bed at five.
I'm getting up at four
or five, which is good,
but no, I think there's
like a different emotion
that has come through having a daughter.
And man, she's just wonderful.
She's just wonderful.
She's just started walking.
She knows what her eyes and head and mouth
and blah, blah, blah.
And she's on the verge
of talking and just,
it's incredible to watch
all these things happen.
- [Kelly] It is so cool.
It's so exciting how fast they change.
Like every, it's such a cliche statement,
but they change so quickly, so fast.
Well, your new album is called Equals.
So what's this all about?
Other than being equal.
- Well, no, the equal sign actually comes,
I feel like being 30,
like equals is at the end of a question
and the start of an answer.
And I feel like my twenties were just
a hell of a lot of questions.
And my thirties, now all those questions
are starting to get answered,
for better or for worse.
And yeah, so the album is just,
I'd say it's a quarter life crisis album,
but it's essentially like turning 30,
getting married, having a kid,
losing a friend and sort of figuring out
who I am around all of that.
- Yeah. I love that.
Well, a lot of people are
going to relate to that.
I cannot wait to hear it.
We're all dying to hear it.
You're touring again, which
I know a lot of artists,
you know, we're all
stoked to be doing again.
(audience cheering)
So where are you looking
forward to playing?
Are you looking forward
to like hometown shows?
- Yeah. Do you know?
I'd never really do hometown shows until
the end of the tour.
'Cause that sort of feels
like the time where you finish
and that's the celebration.
So I'm looking forward,
I'm playing some cities
and islands that I've never played before.
I always loved touring islands,
but to be honest,
the first leg of the tour,
I'm doing the kind of places
where it's safe to do shows
at the moment in Europe,
where they've sort of had festivals
and it's tried and tested and
everything's COVID secure.
'Cause I just want to see
if the tour works first
before bringing it elsewhere.
So I'm excited to play London.
I'm excited to play Paris.
I'm excited to play all
the cities in Germany,
but I will be coming
to the States in 2023.
All the dates are getting finalized now
and its getting back out there.
(audience cheering)
- Don't you be a liar, you
better bring your show here
'cause I wanna go.
It's nice to see you and thank you so much
for zooming in.
- Kelly, can I just say,
can I just say it was such a wonderful day
hanging out with you on The Voice
and I just think you're
such a fabulous person,
and I can't wait to see you soon.
So thank you for having me back.
- Well, thank you! Thank you,
see, the jacket did buy love.
(audience clapping)
Once again Ed's new
album is called Equals,
be sure to check it out everybody.